depuis 1982 la régie renault planche sur
la voiture électrique résultat concret
de ces recherches
ce véhicule break baptisée renault
express fabriqués dans les usines de
billancourt
cette traction avant propulsée par un
moteur à disposition transversale ne
présente aucune caractéristique
révolutionnaire tout au plus quelques
progrès notamment les batteries un bloc
de 18 unités
les composants sont le nickel et le fer
en attendant mieux car l'ensemble reste
toujours pondéreux cette voiture dont
l'autonomie est de 120 km peut rouler
sans problème à 90 à leur performance
intéressante
il s'ajoute à d'autres qualités
évidentes au volant lorsqu'on se promène
volant d'une voiture électrique il ya
deux choses qui frappe d'abord c'est le
niveau sonore qui est extrêmement faible
et puis la facilité de conduite
pas d'embrayage parce que pas de levier
de vitesses est dans une voiture un seul
bord agrément les facilité de conduite
voici la démonstration bonjour l'a40 à
l'heure sur le petit round
je m'arrête
[Musique]
à la place de la boîte à vitesses le
point moeurs ou point zéro je veux des
mariages - sur la position avant et
j'accélère tout simplement
c'est exactement la même chose pour la
marche arrière
[Musique]
on s'arrête
on soumet au point zéro équivalent au
poids mort situation de marche arrière
c'est vraiment l'enfance dollars alors
malgré ces avantages rémy kaizer est ce
que cette voiture à l'avenir nous en
sommes actuellement au stade des études
d'industrialisation et l'avenir sera
dicté par les résultats
d'expérimentations terrain que nous
sommes tout à fait prêts à faire part je
crois que prochainement vous allez faire
un essai grandeur nature dans une ville
moyenne
absolument nous avons en accord avec la
municipalité de châtellerault nous
allons des débuts 86 mettre en
exploitation une dizaine de faumont
bestar électriques qui seront utilisés
par les employés d'habitude la voiture
électrique pour monsieur tout le monde
n'est donc pas pour demain
en revanche on pourrait très vite occupé
le marché utilitaire exemple artisans
livreur à la recherche d'un véhicule
exclusivement urbain pratique maniable
effectuant une multiplication de courtes
distances pendant la journée
car la nuit évidemment on recharge les
batteries en conclusion est il valable
de continuer de longues et coûteuses
recherche pour banaliser la voiture
électrique
oui car la france est plutôt en avance
sur ses principaux concurrents etats
unis japon grande bretagne italie
oui encore si le gouvernement ne décide
pas demain une taxation exagéré de ce
nouveau carburant que peut devenir
l'électricité
[Musique]